and john and sam so what is that what is
your most viral video what is the number
one video that you've posted a question
no it's not it's an easy question it's
probably a tough answer for you because
i don't really what is the most viral
video you're on youtube so youtube's our
smallest platform look there he is the
island boy's new cup yeah granny without
our teeth a little bit flux in there you
can see we actually had to pull the
teeth out because the grille would not
stand we heard this story
um
our most viral video i i i really yeah
there's a lot of them
well grandma goes grandma tends to go to
uh we have a couple prank videos and a
couple of self-defense videos that are
pretty funny well she looks great let me
just tell you that she is oh my gosh
fantastic look at this one of
bodybuilders at conventions yeah look at
her climb up this trampoline here
are you serious
yeah it took like an hour at a speed
round she's not doing it that fast no
it's speed ramp yeah
yeah for sure that took about 20 minutes
and she just sent it i said grandma you
sure you want to do this i couldn't
that's not her it is
same bat in the back and everything yeah
i mean come on
okay i don't know our emotions
blue it is her but
if it's not her you don't give away
secrets that's not what this show's
about come on you know you know i saw
that my name is july wait is that her in
the uh that's that nice that's a nice
blanket a section i went to go try to
buy one of those after i saw that fan i
think sent that to us really really
funny and they got us a
yeah this is one of the lowest parts of
my career but um
you look good
this is just like two weeks old yeah
that's two three weeks old i saw that we
follow you i follow you i'm a fan
appreciate it i am um so yeah it's been
uh and there's the guys in an apple what
are you what are you doing what's up
pumpkin latte we have a guy every year
who like grows world record pumpkins and
last year we dropped it on a smart car
the year before we rolled sammy down a
hill inside of it and then this year
we're like we made a boat for them they
actually they float we were the pumpkin
pirates uh and then we made a pumpkin
spice latte out of it the world's the
biggest one it's fantastic how do you
come up with all these ideas i have a
weird head i think
i see granny in the just in the in the
thumbnail it says 20 million 20 million
what
followers
she's got you beat she does she has me
beat by more than double yeah wow she's
got me by more than 20 million
there you go you're not on tick tock are
you doing that
but i am on
i'm on twitter at ludino's
the act signing right so i
well someone's trying to plug themselves
over here
well he gets really rough do you guys
read your uh comments oh yeah you know
it depends on the platform and what i'm
posting you know if it's like that
middle one up there i don't know if it's
gonna be pervy uh you know
or it's gonna be fun you know family
stuff you know everyone's a little bit
different but sometimes people are mean
and but for the most part let's say 95
percent of people are like
crazy heartwarming and it's weird
because i'm like not a motivational
platform we're doing comedy but people
send such motivational things like how
we've inspired them to reconnect with
like lost family to reach for the stars
you're inspiring people yeah and these
guys you know that's nice that you get
inspiring stuff john and i get called
oompa loompas and i love it though like
i don't know the hate is hilarious it
makes me want to feel more honestly
lose like that too yeah me too yeah you
and i have so much in common i should go
to the convention you've had a three-way
before
lou
three-way before i gotta make sure lou's
is not married no puts himself a pickle
here i've never had a three-way before
well if you ever want to hit us up thank
you
you are so weird wait they're not
getting along right now go ahead what
are you saying you don't want lou with
the with that girl i can't get a
first-class trip to paris with lou in it
right like i can't go see the eiffel
tower no
how does everybody bring up the eiffel
tower on this show
[Music]